انا الليي تقريبا هنا ثلاث او اربع ساعات
وغير له من 6 الصبح عشان يصحه يشحن جواله
لو 20% يتواصل ويطمن على باقي اصدقائه
عيلته امه ابوه واخوه انه اساسا احنا مش
عارفين ايش صار
[موسيقى]
فينا متواجدين ه طبعا زي ما انتم شايفين
بحاول نشحن جوالاتنا نا ست ايام تقريبا
منعزلين عن العالم كله لا معنا راديو ولا
معنا جوال لا نعرف اخبار الناس ولا نتواصل
مع اي
[موسيقى]
حدا ممكن في احد من الموجودين اخوه مستشهد
او ميت وهو ما بيعرف لانه مش ساكنين مع
بعض فيش الرجال هذا طبعا عنده طاقه كل
المربع هذا هو الوحيد حل للناس
[موسيقى]
هذه احنا عننا طاقم شمسيه خدر الناس الناس
تتواصل مع بعضها الناس توصل مع اهاليها
اللي بره الناس مشتتين الناس النازحين في
ناس مرضى بتيجي تشحن بطاريات عان عندها
اجهزه الاكسجين عندها اجهزه
[موسيقى]
التبخيره
مش عارفين ايش نسوي وين نروح وين نيجي
القصف امبارح ه عننا في الدير قصف ودار
والله اللي
سطرنا تبهدلنا يعني يعني كل العريش اللي
عاملين الخيمه اللي عاملينها طارت وجاي
شتا وجاي
[موسيقى]
سقعه
لا خبز الخبز على الطوابير يعني بالعاف
ابصر يصحلك ربطه خبز تسد جو الاطفال اللي
معان معان يمكن فوق ال 15 طفل هذا غير
الكبار في عننا نساء حوامل نساء الحوامل
هدول بدهم غذاء
خاص